it's a labor-intensive process
counting by hand bullets from nearly 2
000 polling stations across several iraq
provinces
this came about after supporters of
political parties that lost seats
demanded our account
the representatives have been monitoring
the process
today we've recounted over a hundred
stations we are comparing current and
old results to see if there is a
difference between manual and electronic
numbers
in this case we go by manual count then
we'll announce the new results day by
day there is more than 50 observers here
iraq's parliamentary election earlier
this month which was moved up to meet
the demands of protesters
so a turnout of 41 percent
that's the lowest figure in the
post-saddam hussein era
the block affiliated with the
influential shia leader mukhtar
173 seats the most of any party
however the pro-iranian multi-party
al-fatiha alliance
secured only 17 seats down from 48 in
the last election several previously
dominant political parties have rejected
the election results
accusing the electoral commission of
vote rigging
the commission says
it has received more than 1400 appeals
so far
but it says
it has turned down most of them because
they're not supported by
for evidence than a week
supporters of the losing parties have
been protesting near the entrance to
baghdad's green zone
most of these protesters are members of
the iran-backed popular mobilization
forces
the military arm of the shia al-fatiha
alliance
security measures have been tightened
around the area which is home to the u.s
embassy
other international diplomatic missions
and government offices that followed
threats made by the protesters to storm
into the green zone
they have denounced the u.n mission
which monitored the election
and accused it of facilitating fraud
two thousand polling stations will not
change much we want manual recount of
all votes in all provinces in the
presence of neutral international
observers otherwise there will be
escalations and will demand the
re-election many people also say the
recount will not change much
supporters of the popular mobilization
forces have organized sporadic
protesters across the country in recent
days
they burned tires and blocked roads
north and south of baghdad
for them the election result is crucial
for their future
and if their political parties can't get
into parliament
they fear they'll have nobody to look
out for their interests
al jazeera baghdad